hey what's up everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we have some pretty
cool news concerning deadpool and stan
lee today now obviously it was
incredibly sad when stan lee passed away
while there were many people who
definitely played a part in marvel
comics and marvel studios there probably
wouldn't be any of this without stan lee
and we got used to his beloved cameos in
marvel studios projects but
unfortunately we haven't seen any cameos
obviously since he passed away but there
was talk and a little bit of hope that
they would still include him in some of
these projects in some way shape or form
then um let there be carnage had him on
a newspaper at the end of spider-man no
way home they had sort of a stanley
look-alike sitting at the diner but we
haven't seen him in any recent mcu
projects but it looks like that is
actually about to change and we have
some really good news concerning
deadpool today so let's break down this
latest news and of course if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos so let's
start off with deadpool because it's
kind of the quicker news right now but
great news as it's officially in
production over at marvel studios now
they've been working on this for quite
some time now but it's pretty much just
been ryan reynolds working on what he
thinks the movie should be then he got
the maulanos sisters involved and now he
has new writers as well over from marvel
studios and now things are getting
rolling and now we have an official
update from the official deadpool movie
twitter account that says deadpool 3
update we've nailed down bran
integrations story character and script
next now if you look closely they show a
picture of peter and we can
automatically tell that this is actually
a picture from deadpool 2 where they
were having auditions for the x-force
and peter shows up but if you look
closely at the jacket he's wearing on
the right side it says mint mobile which
of course is the cell phone company that
ryan reynolds owns so that is the joke
about brand integration but then he says
the story character and script are next
now like i said he's been working on the
script for a pretty long time and
there's been about five writers working
on the script so far ryan reynolds being
the main one but now it looks like it's
time to officially start working on
things with kevin feige getting the
script nailed down the story nailed down
and the characters who are going to
appear nailed down as well so things are
really really moving for deadpool 3 i'm
expecting this film is going to be
coming out within the next two years
hopefully there are some 2024 dates that
don't have movies assigned to them yet
i'm hoping that deadpool is assigned to
one of these spaces and i'm hoping it's
a deadpool kills the fox universe
storyline but let me know what storyline
you would like to see and let me know
how you would like to see deadpool enter
our main mcu now as far as stan lee is
concerned something pretty cool has
happened recently in a very interesting
way stanley is actually returning to
marvel studios and will continue to
cameo in movies and shows in the mcu
marvel has signed a 20-year deal with
stan lee universe which is a venture
between genius brands international and
pow the deal is to license the name and
likeness of stan lee for use in future
feature films and television productions
as well as disney theme parks various
experiences and merchandising now of
course stan lee passed away in 2018 and
some people are wondering well what
exactly are they going to do well this
is what andy hayward chairman and ceo of
genius brands had to say it really
ensures that stan through digital
technology and archival footage and
other forms will live in the most
important venue the marvel movies and
disney theme parks it's a broad deal so
they're gonna use archival footage so
footage that they already have of stan
lee and put that footage into movies and
they'll probably shape it around some
type of a narrative that makes sense for
his cameo and they will also probably
use some cgi there as well since they
say they're going to use digital
technology and other forms besides
archival footage now some people like
this idea and some people don't some
people say let the man rest in peace
while others say this is probably what
stanley would have wanted and i have to
agree i think stan lee would think that
this is really cool i think using
archival footage would be a really
interesting way to keep him alive in the
marvel universe to have his heart and
soul still kind of in that world the
world in which he played a huge huge
role in creating he had cameos in almost
every marvel movie before he passed away
and i think this would be a really cool
way to carry on his spirit in that
universe but let me know what you think
in the comments down below do you like
this idea or do you think that they
should just stop all together don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof